[Music]
whose idea was it to put Dan up against
dolphin oh you know I I think we we goes
your own idea bro was it my idea you
have no one to blame but yourself for
getting punched
[Music]
it's a song of self struggle and kind of
you know feeling like you beat yourself
up a lot but it also has brought you to
you know your greatest successes in life
and so then it was like okay how do you
know maybe it's gonna be an older
version of myself it's kind of being
beating a younger version of himself up
and kind of that wrestle that happens
within like this the conscious and and
and then we were like well this record
for you it has a lot of eighties themes
and it felt like we always liked like
cold sticky kind of stuff I want to stop
[Music]
we can't did you walk away with any
injuries that I know a lot of it's movie
magic ah no I I genuinely was punched in
in the face and in the head oh how many
times probably like 20 times probably
yes
he was cool and he's professional but we
wanted it I didn't want it to you know
to be took me false and then and then
there was one time actually when we were
shadow boxing where you know you to get
close beat on bunch and he caught me in
the John action it was my fault actually
because I moved in and I wasn't supposed
to and I felt like my knees definitely
like buckle and I was like okay this is
what it's like to actually be caught in
the jaw like but at I would say the next
day my head I definitely my brain like
shook a little a night like that feeling
it I wasn't bruised up but my head felt
your brain your brain was bruised my
brain felt yeah a little strange but
what are we talking about I know yes
what's it like after you know you spend
a day getting punched in the face by
Dolph Lundgren everybody I think
everybody wants to like be able to say
they were punched by Dolph Lundgren so I
wasn't at I was like that you know this
is thank you for punching me in the face
Dolph you know and he took it easy on me
he's that dude is he's a real deal he's
brutal and super cool just a young gun
with the quick fuse I was uptight wanna
let loose you went to Dubai with Joseph
Khan which is incredible tell me about
the significance of that video when we
were on set shouldn't believer I think I
turned to Wayne and we were talking
about thunder and and I think I don't
know how it happened but both of us were
just like you know when I hear that song
I think of aliens in Dubai that
literally was like not like that's what
happy explain that to me why does it
make I think I think we as a band we
like sci-fi a lot
like we're all sci-fi nerds and
something about that song is kind of
eerie in strange in some ways but it's
also you know lyrically about feeling
like an outcast a bit so we wanted to
significantly like put that into like
show these different three types of
alien beings that were unique but also
really rad and could do cool dance moves
and have a lot to offer the world and so
and it's the skyline of Dubai is kind of
hard to Bailey and it's kind of alien
like looking the city so we went up to
yeah we we sat down and we were like
with like these three beams like
doo-doo-doo when like there's aliens and
then they dance and that's all we knew
and then we went to Joseph and he was
like aha
let me make this dream a reality and
make it ten times cooler